bonjour gérer un vestiaire mais aussi
derrière de répondre à nos questions sur
rt france pourquoi cet accord a mis tant
de temps à aboutir selon vous et bien
parce que d'abord on venait d'une
situation très difficile qui est la
situation du 6 mars
où donc la russie avait décidé à de
refuser une baisse de production de
pétrole et donc à cette époque nous est
tout simplement sur une situation de
baisse de la consommation chinoise
or depuis lors il y a eu effectivement
la pandémie mondiale
et dans cette situation l'ensemble des
producteurs de pétrole ont été dans
l'obligation de revoir leur position et
donc d'aboutir à un accord de réduction
de production c'est ce délai qui était
nécessaire de cinq à six semaines pour
trouver ce rapprochement alors que l'on
venait de position fort différent alors
les états unis un soutien de cet accord
pour favoriser leur industrie de pétrole
de schiste en grande difficulté la
russie venait d'en parler elle sauvait
les meubles
est ce qu'on peut dire que la crise
sanitaire aplani les différends entre
moscou et washington donald trump elle
vadimir poutine justement est évoquée je
cite la grande importance de cet accord
non je crois pas qu'il y ait de
l'aplanissement de le besoin ou
d'applaudissements des différences comme
vous le disiez je pense qu'il ya
simplement un rapprochement d'intérêt il
était de l'intérêt du monde entier dans
le domaine de la production de pétrole
d'arriver à cet accord de façon à
pouvoir ramener le niveau de prix soit
du prix du brent soit du prix du pétrole
américain wti est bien dans des zones de
rentabilité acceptable pour les
producteurs donc c'est à un
rapprochement d'intérêt qui s'est fait
avec le temps devant la crise un
consensus qui marque aussi un autre
événement celui de la reprise du
dialogue entre moscou et ryad pourquoi
est ce qu'il y avait
des intérêts divergents entre la russie
et l'arabie saoudite et bien tout
simplement parce que après trois ans
d'accompagnement stratégique entre ryad
et et moscou depuis donc fin 2016
la russie déjà à la fin de 2019 avait
décidé de ne plus opérer de diminution
de production et donc sas avait été acté
par l'ensemble de l'industrie pétrolière
russe même s'il y avait des voix
dissonantes igor setchine le président
de rose nef avait été l'avocat de ce
changement
et dans dix ans nous allons plus baissé
de production c'est aux américains
maintenant de diminuer la leur en donc
par cette pression que la russie voulait
faire sur les prix et à bien comme on
vient de l'expliquer il ya quelques
minutes la situation du coc vide 19 la
pandémie réduisant la consommation
mondiale il était nécessaire pour la
russie de revenir sur une vision de
réduction de production
et quid de cet accord lorsque la crise
du coronavirus sera fini on bien je
crois que la borne nous en avons pour un
certain temps à ce que la consommation
de pétrole reviennent à des zones
pratiquement normale
il faut savoir que la le très moyen de
transport à savoir terrestres aériens
maritimes représente plus de 50% de la
consommation n'est ce pas dans le monde
or c'est justement ces déplacements
aériens terrestres et maritimes qui sont
sous le reculoir fortement et il va
falloir donc que les habitudes de
transport reprennent leurs pleins droits
pour que à nouveau la consommation
puisse s'élever dont cela va prendre au
moins un à deux trimestres
ce matin les prix du brut ont
on dit en asie est ce qu'on peut dire
que l'objectif est atteint certainement
alors tout dépend du niveau déjà à la
semaine dernière on a eu des poussées
entre 35 et 40 dollars le baril de brent
il tout porte à croire que l'on va
retrouver à ces niveaux cette semaine il
ya eu une baisse dans un deuxième temps
encore qu'il n'ya l'accord n'étaient
plus en vue maintenant que l'accord est
scellé
nous allons certainement nous retrouver
vers des niveaux de 35 à 40 dollars le
baril mais on les proches de nos joueurs
vont le dire merci gérer un vestiaire
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes un chercheur
associé à la féuo la fondation d'études
pour le moyen-orient